So nowadays,
when you watch
Republicans campaign against Democrats,
they don't campaign
much on what they used to,
which was, you know, the Democrats
or big spenders or whatever.
You know what?
It's all about critical race theory.
And it's all this cancel culture stuff.
Yes.
The biggest
why does it work and what should the
what should Democrats do?
Are they falling for a bait
and doing this
and talking about these issues?
I mean,
I don't know if they're falling
for a bait,
but I mean, I think, again,
I don't even think
half of the Republicans are do it
even mean it.
I think it's they think it's
they think it's worth Right.
What would you do
if you were out of governing ideas
if you if you didn't know how to govern
a country of this magnitude
in a country of this diversity.
And you basically are running on
government is broken.
And then when you get in office,
you have to be terrible
to prove the original premise Like,
it must be great to be able to do that.
This government doesn't work.
And by me not funding it and breaking it.
See? See what I told you?
Keep me in power.
If you don't have ideas on governing,
what do you do?
Well, you do
the purposeful distortion field
that they create.
But but it. And by the way. Right.
Because it's emotional. It doesn't work.
I don't lose the president.
Well, but,
I mean, it doesn't necessarily work.
It gets people upset.
It gets them angry.
It makes them fearful about threats
and and hyper
you know, hyperbole and makes them
afraid of things
that can't even really be defined.
Meanwhile, ignoring so many issues
that it's a kind of real appeal to
your base that you still got.
When Sarah
Huckabee Sanders did the response
to the State of the Union
I noticed she she kept talking about CRT.
She didn't even bother to spell it out to
I don't think it must be.
I would assume most average of,
you know,
what is the guy who came up with that?
That's purposeful.
He's made
his plan is make everything CRT.
And by the way,
all this
diversity initiatives and CRT and
all those other things
are only there because we
refuse to actually fix the real problem.
The diversity
in equity initiatives are a salve.
There are to pacify and mollify
because we won't actually do
the real thing.
We won't actually dismantle
the vestiges of all the systemic racism
and all the systemic classism
and all the systemic gender issues.
We won't actually dismantle that.
But what we will do is
you can have an office in the building,
and every few months
we're going to have to sit
and listen to you talk for like an hour.
And so we're good, right?
Like, it's a country that won't face the.
I'll explain it
like, okay, the NFL.
Right.
You know, the Rooney Rule,
the Rooney Rule in the NFL is
because there are so few
African-American coaches,
you have to at least interview
like one of them.
So that's the rule now
instead of
it's the thing
you put in place
instead of looking at the owner's box
and realizing, oh, right.
That's just the legacy
of the economics segregation
that's been in our country
since its founding.
So we're never going to deal with that.
So here's what we are going to do.
A diversity and equity initiative.
We're going to have to
talk to one black guy.
So are we good?
I think we're good.
But that's
what I'm
what I'm trying to say is we don't.
The thing that they're pointing at
is the thing that's in place
because we won't do the actual thing.
You sound
like somebody who has a lot of anger
and a lot of rage.
And yet you get your very funny
ed and like, how do you how do you keep
all that together?
Like, there's a part of you
that's very optimistic.
I'm very optimistic.
But you sound angry.
I don't mean to sound like a therapist.
No, no, no. I understand.
But wouldn't you?
Why aren't.
Why isn't everybody about real things?
I mean, you want to be
upset about real things,
but isn't that what drives comedy
or art or anything is emotion.
Whether it's anger or joy or love or
what?
Are there other emotions?
There's got to be more than that.
Sadness probably in there.
Envy, hate, envy.
Okay.
That's something that
I was just very gelling in the game.
Oh, no, no, I understand that.
Just top of mind.
It was top of mind.
You know, these are
it's hard to watch.
It's hard to watch a state.
You talk about Sarah Huckabee Sanders.
It's hard to watch a state
that's like 48th
in, you know,
infant mortality and child poverty
and literacy
and make a big deal about dollars
a trans girl that wants to play soccer.
That doesn't.
That happens like once every five years.
They're like, it's hard to not be angry
about people that try and distract
from the real things that people face
with
weaponized nonsense.
I get that. My point is.
But then you also turn it into humor
sometimes.
Sometimes I just turn it into anger
and then sometimes
I just turn it into gummies.
And late at night,
I just take a bunch of those.
And that helps.
For those of you watching at home,
don't do drugs stay in school.